COMPLETE.
HE'S TAKING ISSUE IN THIS LINE
IN THIS REPORT SAYING THIS
OFFICER WHO COULD HAVE TAKEN THE
GUNMAN OUT BEFORE HE WENT INTO
THE SCHOOL, YOU KNOW, EVERY DAY
WE COVER THIS STORY THERE'S
SOMETHING NEW THAT COMES OUT,
AND FOR THESE FAMILIES, THIS IS
WHAT IS SO FRUSTRATING.
THEY STILL HAVE NOT GOTTEN
BRIEFINGS FROM INVESTIGATORS
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED AT THE
SCHOOL.
BUT YET THERE ARE REPORTS OUT
THERE NOW, THERE'S TESTIMONY
FROM OFFICIALS, AND SO THIS IS
WHAT WE TALKED TO THEM ABOUT
YESTERDAY.
I SAT WITH ALMOST 50 DIFFERENT
FAMILY MEMBERS YESTERDAY, AND
THIS WAS ONE OF THE KEY THINGS
THEY WERE FRUSTRATED WITH.
TAKE A LISTEN TO SOME OF WHAT
THEY SAID.
>> JUST BECAUSE OF ALL THE LIES,
THE DECEITFULNESS FROM THE
BEGINNING, IT WAS JUST LIKE
PUTTING SALT ON AN OPEN WOUND.
AND IT'S JUST REALLY HARD
BECAUSE THERE'S JUST SO MUCH
SUFFERING, AND IT'S HARD TO
GRIEVE WHEN THERE'S NO CLOSURE.
>> Reporter: WHEN YOU SAY
THERE'S NO CLOSURE, WHAT ARE YOU
LOOKING FOR?
>> I WANT PEOPLE TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
WE KNOW THAT THE SHOOTER IS
DEAD.
THERE'S NO ONE TAKING
ACCOUNTABILITY.
NO ONE.
>> Reporter: YOUR DAUGHTER.
>> YES, SIR.
>> Reporter: WHEN YOU HEAR ABOUT
SOME OF THE NEW INFORMATION
THAT'S NOW COME OUT, WHAT ARE
YOU THINKING?
>> THEY'RE POINTING FINGERS,
THEY DID THIS, THEY DIDN'T DO
THAT.
I MEAN, NOT BEING IN CHARGE.
WHOEVER WAS THERE SHOULD HAVE
DONE THEIR JOB AND THEY DIDN'T.
YOU KNOW, WHETHER IT WAS
COWARDICE OR -- THEY DIDN'T
FOLLOW THE ORDERS.
I DON'T KNOW, BUT I WANT TO
KNOW.
THEY SHOULD HAVE GONE IN AND
STOPPED THEM.
THAT WAS THEIR TRAINING TO STOP
AN ACTIVE SHOOTER.
THAT'S THE FIRST THING THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO DO, AND IT'S
AGGRAVATING THAT THEY DIDN'T DO
THAT.
>> Reporter: DO YOU THINK THE
OFFICERS WERE COWARDS?
>> THAT DAY, YES.
I CAN'T SAY ALL OF THEM, BUT THE
ONES THAT WERE IN THERE,
OBVIOUSLY THEY WERE, BECAUSE
THEY DIDN'T DO THEIR JOB.
>> Reporter: I CAN'T IMAGINE
WHAT YOU'RE THINKING AS A POLICE
OFFICER WHEN YOU HEAR ABOUT
THESE FAILURES.
>> I LIVE IN SAN ANTONIO, IT
TOOK ME 50 MINUTES TO GET FROM
SAN ANTONIO TO COME HERE TO
UVALDE, THEY TOOK 77.
I LOVE MY BROTHERS IN BLUE BUT
IT'S JUST LIKE ANY PROFESSION,
THIS PROFESSION IS NOT MADE FOR
EVERYBODY.
YOU KNOW, IT'S FINE AND DANDY,
YOU KNOW, YOU GRADUATE FROM THE
ACADEMY, YOU GET THE BADGE BUT
WHEN IT'S TIME TO SUIT UP, WHEN,
YOU KNOW, STARE DEATH IN THE
FACE, YOU KNOW, THEY WENT WEAK
IN THE KNEES.
>> ONE THING I DO WANT IS THOSE
OFFICERS THAT WERE IN THOSE
HALLWAYS, I WANT THEM TO RESIGN.
>> Reporter: YOU WANT ALL OF
THOSE OFFICERS GONE THAT WERE IN
THE HALLWAY.
>> YES.
THE MINUTE I HEARD MY MOM IS
DEAD, I YELLED OUT, I SHOULD
HAVE TAKEN THAT BULLET.
BECAUSE I'M IN THE MILITARY.
I KNOW WHAT HAS TO BE DONE.
I SIGNED UP FOR THAT.
MY MOM PROTECTED THOSE KIDS, BUT
NO ONE PROTECTED HER.
SO THE WHOLE POLICE DEPARTMENT
HERE ARE COWARDS.
>> MY DAUGHTER WAS A
FIGHTER.
TOOK A BULLET TO THE HEART, AND
STILL FOUGHT.
SHE FOUGHT HARD TO STAY ALIVE.
THESE COWARDS COULDN'T GO IN.
>> Reporter: AND ALISYN, THAT'S
THE THING THAT'S REALLY TOP OF
MIND FOR SO MANY OF THE FAMILY
MEMBERS.
YOU SAW THEM SITTING BEHIND ME,
LITERALLY 50 DIFFERENT FAMILY
MEMBERS THAT WE GOT A CHANCE TO
TALK TO YESTERDAY, ALL WONDERING
WHY THE POLICE OFFICERS DIDN'T
GO IN SOONER, ALL WONDERING WHAT
COULD HAVE HAPPENED, YOU KNOW,
PERHAPS SOME OF THEIR FAMILIES
WOULD HAVE BEEN SAVED BUT ALSO
THE TRAUMA, THE TRAUMA FOR THE
SURVIVORS, THOSE KIDS, WHO
SURVIVED, THAT HAD TO STAY IN
THAT ROOM FOR MORE THAN AN HOUR.
ACTING LIKE THEY WERE DEAD.
JUST DEVASTATING, AND THE TRAUMA
THAT THEY WILL ENDURE FOR THE
REST OF THEIR LIVES, AND NOW
THIS FAMILY, THIS COMMUNITY,
THESE FAMILIES, ALL THEY WANT
ARE ANSWERS AND THEY WANT
ACCOUNTABILITY, AS YOU HEARD
THERE, AND SO THE MAYOR, YOU
KNOW, I SPOKE TO THE MAYOR
EARLIER UNTIL THE WEEK.
HE SAID THERE'S LIKELY GOING TO
BE SOME CHANGES.
RIGHT NOW WHAT HE'S FOCUSED
ON,
HE SAYS IS GET